all right sugas hi sugas uh hello where
are you from originally where did you
grow up I'm from Thailand the North of
Thailand how far from Bangkok it's right
out
600 kilometers yeah he's calling us
Xiang Mai
yes and that is
where your family is from that's where
you grew up but
my family before like when I'm young my
family that I live in Bangkok so I am
live here with the family but then I'll
just moved back to the hometown like
seven years ago yes oh
I am now in Bangkok but my family they
are at the hometown yep tell me about
your childhood how you grew up
um
when you were a young small oh yeah
child when I'm young and small yes I do
later
the same like the normal like a young
girl and don't know what what they are
what I am and none and
one day I feel like I want to be like
Lord I want to be like a girl yeah so my
mom that I know me me yes you are not
not the highly person guy or something
man so but the first night is funny
my dad is not okay the the before yeah
Uncle so when
I like a seven year old I get like a
little bit so my mom supports me a
little bit and when I am kind of take
the hormone yes and my mom gave me love
money for the by some the hormone and
I'm sad take the hormone from that yes
so your mom accepted it and supported it
yes and but like I feel little bit so my
daddy there are subtle
that you are being a nine percent good
person so we are okay so that I am happy
now
you started taking the hormones at what
age
I think oh
13 something like that because you know
I want to be sad like a young girl but
sometimes doctors say it's not not good
to be like you know
because if you're not not really know
about the hormone it's not good to take
right are you taking hormones currently
yes you still do yeah yeah and you've
had surgeries
I have the move fertility and some like
I know or something
yeah in the club that you work at which
is full of beautiful yes all the
beautiful girl there trans females
what's the name of the club it's the
opposition Obsession that the girls
there have some male equipment yeah
all of them oh we all have the same yeah
and uh you've been working at this club
it's like a
a place that men can go to date these
women and yeah take them to their rooms
and have fun right you can
can get a the person can get that come
have something and talking it okay so
can can have some good time
yes
how long have you worked there
you mean about this bar or well how long
have you done that kind of work
oh like before I live in the Phuket
store and
okay
but the most I live in Bangkok because
before before my like I say my family
here in Bangkok yeah
and your customers the men that that
will pay you for a date they're from
America they're from uh yes there are
many or yes but uh
America England Germany Australia or yes
Europeans yes probably Asian too right
so many Asian yeah it's surprising how
many men are into trans women sometimes
I want to try something new yes there
are some of these guys yes some guy want
to try something new right but are some
of these guys married with women they
have girlfriends but they're yes but
some that are open you know that and
some that are just looking want to try
something new you know so everyone had
should have to be first time yes so
let's try something new so when you meet
a guy they can be fooled because you're
bar is full of beautiful females yes
it appears
um do you have to tell the guy that you
are trans
um because I think the when the guy
comes into the bar I think all the of
the guy
you think they figure it out yes because
there are only one only one but
now everyone knows what's going on at
your bar yeah right
welcome and
make them happy so we are happy and
you're happier yeah as a trans woman yes
than you were as a as a male right yeah
do you have any regrets in your life
pardon do you have any regrets in your
life
not so much yes I not like to have the
plan or something like that but maybe in
the future I open the shop for the salon
or the nail shop or some something yes
how old are you I am 30. you're 30. yeah
and uh your family knows that you're
doing this your mom yes yeah that I
don't know about down
is this lifestyle more accepted in
Thailand than in other countries you
think um
not not about
I do this because I like this too so we
do we are happy I don't want a happy so
yeah you enjoy it and mentor
how much money do you make every a night
depends on yeah of course generally you
make
60 to 70
000 per month 70 000 Baht a month yes it
depends on the month maybe some months
gets more maybe someone can list
yeah that's about
two thousand US dollars maybe a little
more oh yeah a month but the cost of
living here is very very low so yes
that probably goes a lot maybe it
depends on the high season low season
yes
and you have regulars guys that will
come see you often
have fun yes are they all tourists
they have some come to the few times but
they have some one time just like like
what I say some somebody just want to
try yes
so it sounds to me like you like this
lifestyle you enjoy it I haven't thought
of because it doesn't depress you
selling your your body yeah I every day
I do this I have
sometimes I miss a new friend meet a new
person and that is good yeah yeah
are you friends with the other
trans women at the club yeah
it seems like you guys all get along
because working here like four months so
I have some that's all that's why I am
inside I have a new good good friend
yeah were there other opportunities for
you in the world but in are there other
jobs you could have done other than this
no but before I help my mom to do the
field of food
their food yeah my mom they are sell
food so
I have them but in the future I have
planned to to open the shop for the nail
or the salon yes
this is your hair we're looking at this
my hair
yeah yeah you're spectacularly beautiful
thank you
are there things that you'd like to do
in your life in the future I mean I
don't know if you'll do this forever
right you'll probably quit at some point
maybe I'm gonna open the
nail salon or things like that yeah but
the one thing I want to do is a cafe
Cafe yeah the cat cafe or something yeah
very nice
how did you first get into this type of
work how did you first discover that
this was an option for you to do this
what can I say yeah before I have
something
asked me to copy them to the Phuket so
yes I start going there to do this so
I know everything yes but I have some
friends before in Bangkok too
so then let me do
ask me to restore I tried this thought I
feel the top is not not hurt everyone
making somebody making everyone happy so
and nothing is bad
do you think as a trans woman that you
you understand what men want in a woman
better than maybe a regular not really
because
I think it's depend everyone so even
like
everyone have
outside not the same yes so
it seems like the women at the yeah yeah
at your club but the one thing we are
have the special is be I have the the
woman not have yes you do
are drugs or alcohol part of your life
or no yeah adding alcohol but I'm not
smoking yeah and alcohol is not a
problem for you no you just drink just
because you're just sitting there all
night yeah
what is the hardest part of this job for
you what is the hardest part of this
this job
for me it's not not being hard because
when I see some guy is bad guy walk away
from them because yeah there's some guys
that are just trouble just have have to
you know if normally you think every top
have this yeah so if I see some some guy
is hard so it's bad guy of course
because we are working now
night time you know in a club of course
you guys are probably drunk yeah but
when someone there so um
are there problems in Thailand for for
Trans people no we are open here yeah
it's pretty pretty accepted here yes it
seems like everybody yeah
is is cool with it
we are
respect people yeah
so guys what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
life about with my family
your family comes first yes yeah that's
great
all right sugas thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you I wish you lots of luck out
there
thank you